وبعد التسليم الخاص بي لذلك لدينا
اكتشفت أنني كنت أحمل الوعاء ونحن
فجأة لم يعد يريدني
ولادة رامون بدونها كانت أ
الظلم يجعله رد فعل غاضب
وسوء الفهم
نشعر حقًا أنه يتبع نجاحًا كبيرًا
في حين أن الإصدار لي
عتاب عندما لم أفعل
من الخطأ دائمًا ما يكون جاهزًا لذلك
الإعارة مرة أخرى من الفريق على المستوى
قال المرضى سيدي بسرعة
التي كان علي أن أقاتل من أجلها ولكن
كما فعلت للتو
ليس مصغرة إنه عالم لاحقًا
مع الكثير من العنصرية كما هم
الإسلاموفوبيا في النهاية
تحولت العجلة في الواقع لصالحي
في هذا المستشفى الظالمين
تم طرد العنصريين وقرأت
بل أعيدت مع من أقول
إنه ن آخر كان هناك الكثير من
غير المستقر وكنت حاملاً في المرتبة الثانية
وفجأة اضطررت إلى نقل سيدة
من كان حامل في ذلك الوقت بتوأم
ليس لديها عمل ل
الولادة لملاحظة السكتات الدماغية أخيرًا
لقد أزعجني حقًا في تلك اللحظة
هناك وفي نفس المساء قلت لنفسي أن علي ذلك
أننا نفعل شيئًا من أجل هؤلاء
الامهات أيضا وقت كان هناك
العديد من اللاجئين عند باب
كنيسة صغيرة حيث أن
انقر وحيث يمكنني الحصول على الكثير من
حان الوقت لإنشاء هذا
تمامًا حيث نعطيها
اذهب إلى الأمهات التي نجهزها
الأمتعة لها حقائب بها كل شيء بداخلها
اللازمة لاستقبال الطفل هي
حفاضات بشكل عام
هناك
لذلك كل هذا تبرعات هو
الناس الذين يعطون أو يعطون
المال بعد شراء المنتجات
زجاجات الأطفال باس وصغيرة
برطمانات أغذية الأطفال
كل هذا ، هذا كل ذلك ، تبرعات
هناك أيضًا شركات تمنحنا
مرات في الشهر بانتظام ربما بلدي
شركة لي خاصة ليس العام
ولكن من يعطينا حقًا ما نحتاجه
يحتاج الشخص المناسب لضرب واحد
سيف اصغر متطوع
ترسل جمعية التساهل ملف
البريد لجميع كنائس باريس في
جعلنا كنيسة واحدة فقط استجابت لنا
أمام الوحيد هو القديس سولبيس و
افعل ذلك أنا لا أمزح في ذلك الوقت
استجاب لنا بحرارة شديدة
يقول إنه يريد أن يكون سعيدًا حقًا
وتشرفنا باستضافة جمعية
الذي يساعد الامهات bd وكان يأمل
أن يتم ذلك بسرعة وأننا
البقاء لأطول فترة ممكنة
[موسيقى]